hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well when you're
reading Plato's symposium and you look
at the different speeches that compose
the bulk of the literary work at first
you might think that they're just sort
of strung together each one happened to
happen let's try this again Plato's
symposium as a work yeah let's say sassy
good girl Plato's symposium as a
literary composition consists in large
part of seven main speeches or seven not
quite speeches but at least blocks of
text where a particular person is the
one who you might say is the dominant
figure and the reason why I say that is
because in Socrates portion he doesn't
play by the rules and give a speech as
everybody before him has but he engages
them in something a little bit different
but we'll get to that in a moment now
you notice that I put all these boxes on
the board I want to run through in this
video some of the you know basic points
about the character
the style and the content of their
speeches before I do that though I want
to stress one point when you first
approach this text it might appear as if
the speeches are kind of happenstance
there's just this one first and that one
acts and there's no necessary order to
it they just happen to wind up in a
place where Socrates can bring things to
a conclusion because he's a smart guy
but if you look at the speeches you're
gonna see the themes from each being
taken up at least in part by the
subsequent speeches so there is a reason
why Plato has them and then the order
that it does Phaedrus is in some respect
criticized by us audience for not having
go on far enough in in discussing you
know not just the goodness but the
badness of love pause audience is going
to be criticized then by Erik Zemeckis
who isn't even actually supposed to
speak at that time but Aristophanes
conveniently gets a bout of the hiccups
and that allows Erik symmachus to slip
in there after giving him some medical
advice Erik Semih kiss is going to say
pal sannyas didn't go far enough
Aristophanes is actually going to sort
of launch into his own thing I need to
put something here and Agathon is going
to come next and Agathon himself will
sort of like bring things back to a
crocs and say all of you then you know
doing this when really you should have
been doing this and I'm about to do it
myself
Socrates then comes after him Socrates
will always bring everybody else's
themes in because he's going to ask
questions and then Alcibiades will bring
things to an end with his speech that
wasn't even supposed to be in there but
all of this hangs together as one
composition with many different voices
blended into it so let's look at each of
these voices in turn Phaedra's a young
man very attractive upper-class he's
been able to study with some of the
really bright minds not only Socrates
but he is
friends or perhaps even lovers with
Erics amicus so he knows a little bit
about about medicine he studied with a
sophist he has not only Socrates as a
friend but also this guy lysias who's a
speech writer so he's got sort of a
melange of different influences coming
in but he's not really that developed
his speech is rather short and in many
respects it's conventional what he does
is begins by praising law as being the
most ancient and the you know ancient
Greece ancient meant something different
than it does to us but antiquity a man
time was sort of a hallmark you would
say you know well you know this is great
because it's old and he says that about
love then he goes on and he praises love
for its relationship to honor how it
brings out the best in those who are
motivated by love he does have one of
the interesting striking image in there
about the army or the city that would be
composed entirely of lovers and
therefore invincible in the field of
battle but that's actually a historical
allusion to the sacred band of Thebes
most likely so you know what we have in
his his speech are a bunch of really
well put together phrases with the right
footnotes added or the right references
the right citations but he's not getting
us you know to the heart of love he
doesn't need praising love but it's not
clear that he has a comprehensive
picture about what love is he's managed
to grasp certain aspects but he hasn't
gone far enough and that's great for a
starting point because then you can
build upon that
that's what post arias does Pausanias is
an older man post audience is actually
the lover of Agathon whose house the
party is it as a matter of fact their
friendship relationship went on long
past the the time in which this would be
expected to sort of come to a close they
appear to have been lifelong companions
posar Gnaeus is going to bring a more
keenly analytical mind to things he's
interested in political phenomena he's
going to talk
about the role that love plays but he's
gonna make a very important distinction
this is where we start to get a bit
philosophical right philosophy is in
significant part about making
distinctions when there needed to be
made when other people aren't making
them and pisani is going to say if a
dress all the stuff that you're saying
about the greatness of love that's only
one kind of love there is also a bad
kind of love as well a bad kind of
erotic desire and that's what gets
people into all these sorts of messes
and that's part of why this love
relationship where you have an older
figure and a younger figure is frowned
upon because most people screw it up but
would it be possible not to screw it up
Posadas is very interested in the laws
or the customs and he contrasts
different peoples different countries
different city-states against each other
arguing ultimately that the Athenian
laws governing this are our best but
they're that point where they should be
and so he's the ends up turning what's
supposed to be a discourse praising log
into a discourse that's a you know in
essence giving legal advice and praising
the lover a lover of a certain sort Erik
so I guess it is I like it but here it's
a technical man he is a medical doctor
and to be a medical doctor at that time
really meant more than than just
focusing on the human body you had to
know about all sorts of other things
that he had a physicalist account of
things he thinks that everything is a
matter of elements which can be broken
down which can be harmonized and he will
take this notion of good and bad love
and refigure it in terms of health and
disease healthy love which is where
there's a harmony between the opposite
elements that need to function whether
they're hot and cold or you know wet and
dry or fire and water or the parts of
the human body or even the the cosmos as
a whole or musical notes he's going to
say we can understand love through the
art of medicine and I just happen to be
the guy who can
tell you all about that in style she's
rather pedantic there there are certain
things that come through much more in
the Greek than they do in the
translation Plato has written it in such
a way that when you're reading him you
can tell this guy you know he knows his
stuff when it comes to his art his
technique but he's not a very good
speaker and he just sort of throws
everything together he uses you know the
the s is P you know subject is predicate
kind of constructions the verb Ani to be
shows up in his his section more than in
anybody else's so he's you know you
remember back when when you were a kid
and you were told don't just say you
know something is doing something or
something is something use an action
verb instead Erickson MCUs doesn't do
much of that so his style reflects is
clear belief that technique that
disciplinary knowledge is the way to
make sense out of this crazy thing that
we call love and so in some ways he
tells a really interesting story about
what we might do but you might think
that that love as the force that we feel
tends to get lost in they're totally
different story with Aristophanes
Aristophanes tells the tale and like I
put here it's a colleague tale
Aristophanes is himself a comedian that
means he writes comic plays of which
fortunately we have quite a few
preserves so if you want to see what
this guy's like you can read his works
and they're pretty funny stuff but it's
also a tragic tale because he's going to
tell this mythical story about the way
back time when human beings were
originally very different than they are
now instead of having one head and two
arms and two legs and one set of
genitals
they had twice as many because they were
these round beings who would roll all
over the place and they got too big for
their britches
Zeus God cuts them in half and has them
sewn up around there's a long story here
I'm not going to go into all the details
but what is getting at with this is some
sort of allegorical account about love
as a desire to find the missing half of
one's own self that one a human being is
not truly a fully human being until they
found their mate the one who was
originally separated from them so love
loss and restoration of the lost unity
this desire to fuse with the other
that's what makes it a tragic tale and
Aristophanes also suggests if we get too
big for our britches maybe the gods will
cut us in half again and make things
even worse for us although they are by
the end of his story pretty bad
Agathon it's at Agathon's house remember
he is the tragic playwright who has won
the contest he's a young promising man
considered quite attractive quite smart
very witty Avery urbane he is a great
host as we find out at the beginning he
also is not only you know writing from
the perspective of tragic poetry but has
been influenced it's very clear by
rhetoric and specifically by the kind of
rhetoric that this guy gorgeous this
master rhetorician and the sophist had
taught because you know we see by the
end of his speech him pulling out all
the stops it's let you know because this
rather measured approach at the
beginning where things are set up with
these wonderful parallelisms and he runs
through this you know two-part argument
that demonstrates you know irrefutably
the both absolute beauty the
wonderfulness of love by appealing to
certain characteristics and then shows
that love actually encompasses and
dominates every single virtue all the
four cardinal virtues justice wisdom
temperance or moderation and courage by
the N if he goes into this flowing
passage of impassioned rhetoric that
brings it to a close
this actually makes him fodder for
Socrates milk and now we get into
Socrates portion if you want to call
this a speech you have to acknowledge it
has two different parts to it there's an
important joining phase between them at
first Socrates says wah I can't talk
like the rest of you guys I just know
how to do this dialectical questioning
and answering you know I don't know if
you'd be interested in that sort of
thing but but let me see if I can do it
I you know I just you know let me let me
give it a try and so everyone's like
yeah I get Socrates yeah that's what you
do and then he comes after a Agathon
who's just given this wonderful speech
and shows that hangeth on doesn't have
any idea what he's talking about get
some all turned around
turns out that love is actually a lack
love doesn't have beauty love is for
beauty which means that it's lacking the
beauty that it desires love doesn't have
virtue love desires virtue love desires
this love desires that because love is a
lack of what ought to be present or what
could be present then we get into this
passage where Socrates introduces
another character they set the one woman
in the dialogue the flute girl who is
gonna play essentially just a hired hand
to you know provide some musical
accompaniment they sent her out there
aren't any other women in the dialogue
Socrates brings one in and he doesn't
just bring in some as like some woman as
a date or hanging out his arm he brings
him the woman who's gonna teach all of
them about love because she actually
knows all of this because she is a
philosopher and a priestess and you know
instruct ryx in love who taught the
young Socrates so is it Socrates speech
or is it do Thomas speech or is it both
should we consider it just to be plato's
speech at this point in any case if we
want to talk about the genre it's a
philosophical initiation she is using
dialectic but back and forth questioning
in part
that she's also unpacking the meanings
of things ranging from pregnancy to the
attraction that we feel to production
and ultimately sketching out for us this
ascent via interrupts love becomes the
way that we move not only towards
beautiful bodies beautiful souls but
even towards beautiful institutions the
virtues and beyond that something yet
higher something totally sublime
something that barely can be named the
form of beauty itself a beauty that if
we glimpse it for a moment we will be
unsatisfied with any other beauty this
is an initiation this is not just a
philosophical treatise with you know
sending things out nicely numbered
paragraphs and providing footnotes this
is the way that philosophy sometimes
does get done and when it's done well
it's it's really the best finally we
finish with the speech that wasn't
supposed to happen but which Plato
brought into this that's what the you
know drunken Alcibiades the sort of
golden boy of Athens at least at that
moment he's gonna fall from grace very
soon bursting in with his revelers and
taking over the party and he engages in
this drunken praise not of love but of
Socrates and he tells an anecdote well
he tells several anecdotes about
Socrates but the most central anecdote
is about how Socrates can't be seduced
Socrates is in a certain sense above
ordinary physical law and though the
traps that we fall into so he has this
discussion of Socrates and sort of like
these these ugly satyr
dolls that you open up and you find a
golden treasure inside
Socrates literally is the ugly guy with
a great personality
that's what Elsa by --'tis is spelling
out for us so it's fitting that after
socrates has just you know brought in
this wonderful discourse about the
nature of love that manages to touch on
and bring in all this other stuff that
we should have somebody coming in to
talk about how Socrates himself figures
into love so that is the contents in
very bullet point terms of these great
speeches and you can see that there's a
progression you can also see that each
one of these persons represents not just
themselves as a character but you might
say a type of human being not only in
what they think but also in what they
say and most importantly in the style in
which they express it